- We're back y'all, celebrating
women doing big things
in the world of sports ball.
As a reporter for ESPN
and now for FOX Sports.
Our first guest has been front and center
at some of the biggest sports
ball events in the world.
She's an ambassador for FOX's
free streaming service, Tubi
and her apparel line wear,
which is super cute by the way.
Just expanded with more styles
to support your favorite NFL teams.
Please welcome, Erin Andrews!
(lively music)
(audience applauding)
- [Kelly] (cheers) Hello!
- What's up?
Hi, I'm apart from you.
- [Kelly] Have a seat.
I know, we can't like touch or hug.
It's weird.
- I know.
- [Kelly] But good for people
that don't like doing that.
I'm just not one of them.
(Erin laughs)
It's great to see you again.
- Good to see you.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I was remembering when
I was pulling up today.
First time I was here, it was like
when you kicked it off.
- [Kelly] I know.
- [Erin] It was your first season, baby.
I loved that you speak
- Congrats.
- [Kelly] in sports ball.
- [Erin] Yes.
- It's when you kicked it off.
- I am gonna teach you somehow, Kel.
- [Kelly] I know, what-
- I am, I promise.
- Yeah, I enjoy it, when I'm at the game.
See, I'm very specific.
- Yes.
- If I'm at the game, the energy of it,
I can get into it and I don't
even know who I'm yelling for,
but I'm excited about it.
- Yeah.
- It's just like a TV.
I don't know.
- Well, I love obviously the food.
- Yes.
- I mean the chicken fingers,
- hot dogs,
- [Kelly] Hot dogs.
- all of it.
(crosstalking)
The beers.
- [Kelly] Yes, yes.
- When you go to Lambeau,
where the Green Bay Packers play.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- Freezing and they have like frozen beer.
- I think I've been there.
Is that where they have the big green?
No, no, no.
- Like the big green what?
- Wait, is that in Boston?
Where is that?
- God, I love you.
- There's a big old green thing.
- The green monster.
- Green monster.
- That's where the Boston Red
Sox played different sport
but it's-
- I played catch in there.
(Kelly laughs)
- They also sell insane hotdogs.
They're called Fenway Franks.
- Dude, I'm gonna tell you,
I got to sing during the whole series.
They ended up breaking their like streak.
It was like, there was some 80-year-
- Curse, yes.
- [Kelly] Yeah, curse.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And I like to think I was a part of it.
Imagine that broke it,
(both laughing)
but it was really inspiring to be there.
I will say
- Yeah.
- that energy was crazy.
Who, speaking of inspiration,
what women inspire you
in sports right now?
- Well, I mean, I love any of
the women that are coming up.
I kinda like how it's
changed over the years
and everybody's kind of
adding their own like kind
of flare and kind of like, you know,
- Yeah.
- [Erin] different way
that they do reporting.
The one girl, I or woman.
I grew up loving.
I used to call her my Michael
Jordan of sports broadcasting.
Her name is Melissa Stark.
And she was, when I was in
college or in high school,
she was kind of like
the one on the sideline.
She was young and she just
really, really held her own.
- So how have you seen sports
help people in this last year?
I'll tell you how it hasn't held is
in a sense that people missed it.
Like all my friends,
- [Erin] Yeah.
- literally, I'm the black sheep
like all my friends
and my sister, everybody,
they love sports.
- Yeah.
- They know everything
about sports and they were really sad
that it was like a void for them.
Like not having that to watch.
- Yeah, well, it was hard when we were
in the middle of quarantine
and everything was happening.
We didn't even know if we would go back
to work for the NFL, right?
But then,
- [Kelly] Wow.
- obviously, thank goodness the NFL
and all the networks figured out a way
like you guys are doing with The Voice.
So and here, have it all on
and try to figure out how
you kind of just regroup.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Erin] But I think sports has been huge
because it just gives
people a sense of relief.
Like when you guys couldn't do your show
or you guys were doing this from home,
I just felt like it was a
good distraction for people.
You know?
- Yeah.
It felt like some kind of normal was left.
- [Erin] Yeah.
People needed that
for a good four hours
of the day to like cheer
and scream for their team and not cheer
and scream at the TV
- Yeah.
- and just be so frustrated
about what was going on, obviously
with corona and so forth.
So it was really, I thought
it was so important.
And we've seen examples of that
like when 9/11 happened
and they got baseball going
and everybody's like, "Should
we play or should we not?"
because of what happened.
And it's like, the country needs it.
The country needs to come
together and feel some excitement
and root for somebody
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- and kind of get the bad taste out
of their mouth for a bit
- Especially, isn't
that like the classic American sport?
- Yes, baseball.
- I feel like that-
Did, do I know that?
- You do, way to go!
- Thank you.
I think I knew something.
I think it's 'cause of
Field of Dreams or a movie.
(Kelly laughs)
- You know more
than you give yourself credit for.
- [Kelly] I really don't.
But every once in a while,
I do know something.
What was your first reporting
job like out of college?
- So my first reporting
job, I'm from the South.
I'm from Florida.
- Yeah.
- [Erin] And like I knew college football
and my first job was with an NHL team.
I knew nothing about hockey,
when I got my first job.
I acted like, you know,
I knew the part, I read CliffNotes
like hockey for dummies.
- Yeah.
- Right
before my first job interview
- Yeah.
- to try to wow them.
And they knew I was full of it.
And I didn't know what I was
talking about, but I was like,
"I'm gonna work so hard.
You're gonna love me."
- [Kelly] Yeah, I love that.
- Girl, look at it,
look at us now.
- You can't know everything.
- No.
- But to have somebody
that's willing to like
really do their homework
and really get in there.
- I was horrible though.
I was bad.
Like you look back now and stuff.
- We all were great when we
started at what we're doing.
- Yeah, right.
- [Kelly] (laughs) Like,
let's all point that out.
So your dad inspired
you to get into sports.
Does he give you advice?
Like while you're on TV?
'Cause my mom will literally be like,
"Why did you turn your
chair for that person?"
(Kelly laughs)
- Yeah.
- And she's very bold with
like her comments to me.
And it's awesome.
But does your dad do that?
- Yeah, so we're live.
So my dad's watching along
as you know,
- Oh.
- the game is.
So he's like texting me during the game
and some people are are always saying,
"You're always on your phone."
I'm like, "Yeah."
'Cause my dad's texting me
during like, "There you go.
Yeah, my dad is texting
me during the game."
He is an investigative reporter.
He just retired.
- [Kelly] Awh.
- [Erin] I hope he gets to
enjoy the retirement soon
and get out of this misery
that everybody's been dealing with.
But he does.
He watches the game.
He'll always say, "Slow down.
You're talking too fast, put
the mic closer to your face."
But then I start to panic,
like if I have a losing interview
or if I know I have a big,
you know, interview coming up,
he'll be like, "Ask him
this, ask him this."
- I always feel like Carson on The Voice
like compared to speaking,
I always feel bad for him.
Like,
- [Erin] Yeah.
- "Oh, my God, what about
the people that walk up
and they don't make it."
Like you've just sit there and you're
with their families like-
- And ask them the questions.
- That's hard.
- Yeah, it is hard.
- Yeah.
- And the hardest one that I always have
to do is the Super Bowl.
For some reason, I always
choose the losing coach.
And you have to interview the losing coach
at the end of the Super Bowl.
This is the biggest game of their life.
(Kelly blows air)
And these poor guys.
I mean, I get so sensitive
when I see them walk in
and they just are like, "Hi, Erin."
And I'm like,
and my dad always texts me,
"Don't look sad.
Don't look sad and stop talking soft.
You have to be like direct."
And I'm like,
"Dad, they've just lost the
biggest game of their life."
"How did that go?"
- But what they probably don't
want is like a pity thing.
They probably don't,
- [Erin] I know.
- you know, that's why.
- [Erin] You're right.
- Yeah, they probably-
- [Erin] Yeah.
- Maybe that's why.
I don't know, that's a hard,
I wouldn't (laughs) have done it.
- It's real hard.
- [Kelly] Pass on that.
- It's Carson times 20.
- [Kelly] Yeah. (laughs)
That is horrible.
Well, you're an ambassador for Tubi
and you've expanded
your clothing line wear,
which is super cute y'all.
- Thank you.
- And so can you tell us a bit
about both of those?
- Yeah, so Tubi is FOX's
new streaming service,
which is really great
because they have over 30,000
movies and TV shows and look,
what did we all do during quarantine?
- Girl.
- Yeah,
we watched the streaming services.
And also like,
would they like to call
themselves the comfort food
of streaming services?
So it's like old movies
- [Kelly] Okay.
- that you forgot you loved so much.
Like the other day, Planes,
Trains and Automobiles.
Did you ever watch it?
- [Kelly] Oh, my gosh!
Yeah, what?
- Those aren't pillows.
(Kelly laughs)
John, Kenny, Angel.
- Oh, my God, I love you.
- [Kelly] You're (laughs)
just, that's amazing.
Well, we're gonna play a game
with flying sports balls next.
Have you?
That's a good tease.
Have you ever been hit by a sports ball?
- I have.
I have been hit at a Major
League Baseball game.
I'll set the scene for you.
I was on third base side, so that's right
where third base is,
first, second, third home.
Third base side, guy hit a line drive,
which means straight across.
There was nothing that broke
like where the ball was coming.
The security guard that was
with me actually ducked,
when it came my way
and I went like this
and it smacked me clear
as day in the mouth.
There it is.
Hot.
- [Kelly] Holy moly.
- [Erin] It bounced off my
face and landed behind me.
But I was fine.
- [Kelly] Dang.
- Doctor said I had a jaw of
steel, you know what I mean?
- Oh my gosh.
That,
I would brag about that.
- Yeah.